hey everyone it's Joanna here and
today's workout I'll be showing you a
series of simple but very effective
workout for you to achieve the flat
tummy that you've always wanted
so if you want to get a flat tummy let's
workout and let's work hard right guys
so let's start with our first workout
lie down your mat instead of your usual
crunches what we'll be doing
it's called crunches with legs extension
so to begin with bring your legs up keep
them 90 degrees with your toes pointed
out and keep your hands just by your
head alright so what you want to be
doing is to crunch up and bring them is
close to you and when you're going down
extend your legs forward so now you can
crunch in that's one that's it crunch we
really go all the way up to leave your
shoulders off we get or really go as low
as you can
five that's it do not bring up and all
the way down six good seven punch all
the way up extend eight extend nine
extend good job ten step one
keep going send to extent as far as you
can
three plus two for last moment and bug
and just rest
good job but these work out who should
be filling your other apps working sy
Sandra laughs so really it's a both your
aqua admin will ask let's go into our
second your account second work out it's
called late raisers so what you really
want to be targeting is here the last
that's why an additional tab you should
be is so just keep it on spiders like
always remember to keep your back
straight flat on the floor your back
your back should not be you know over
extending so just keep your back
straight on the top if you go on the
outside and we build exile pointer and
just lower your legs as low as you can
with the arch in your back and lift it
back up there you can message
one two that's it keep your leg straight
three as long as you can without your
back your job for die and fine if you
find this difficult what you do is you
bend your knees and really jump and just
like this alright alright guys so let's
do ten one go one tip two
we feel your wife's working three four
if your back hurts in what you can do is
just a support high five good six
[Music]
very good
so just shake it off the next workout
it's called bicycle crunches so what you
want to be working with a Space Needle
time to inspect all of their apps they
can't access same thing on this by your
head bring your knees 90 degrees and
when you tweeze what you want to be
doing is to extend one leg forward and
twist the other side bring your legs in
twist and extend bring it in twist and
extend that's it
so one that's it two three six three
that's it
twist all the way for building your side
ABS bringing good choice five twist six
good job
twist seven good Bugis my ABS 8 and
relax
9 good job 2 is 10 oh yeah good one
please - good job last 3 3 good last two
for bringing last one 5 in and just
relax
very good so for our last workout let's
get up into my favorite plank position
ok so if you do not know how to do a
correct plan yet
watch how to videos where I'll be
showing you how to do
step-by-step so let's get into a plank
position and let's hold it for about 45
seconds okay ready okay remember to keep
your body straight all right
really through your entire core working
let's go
ready Anna good job keep your body
straight that's it
really just relax and focus all right
doing good
keep it straight tighten your ass good
job
you should do the covarine and if we do
all these four workouts you know
everything and whatever you can I can
show you these three results and give
that time all right that's good keep
going hold it all right the last ten
seconds let's go let's move our bodies
one in five one two five six seven eight
so those are all simple but very
effective were able to really give you
that flat tummy and you can do all the
workouts within five minutes so just
spend five minutes a day for flat tummy
if you do have any questions don't
forget to leave me your comments and
also don't forget to subscribe to my
page thank you for watching and I hope
that you're feeling your abs burning
right now and all the birds were getting
a flat tummy
you